[music]
as a result of the intrigues of
ill-conceived decisions,
this unit was supposed to cease to
exist on July 1, 23,
no one agreed to sign a contract
with the Ministry of Defense of
Moscow during his experience,
which would lead to a complete loss of combat capability
despite the fact that they did not
show any aggression
but to us  a missile strike was launched and immediately
after that the helicopters worked out
a man
that immediately the council of commanders
decided that we should move out
immediately None of the fighters was
forced to this campaign And everyone knew
his
purpose of the campaign
was to prevent the destruction of the
Wagner dude and bring to justice those
persons who, with their  unprofessional
actions
made a huge number of mistakes in
the course of our own and our decision to turn around
were two most important Factors the
first factor
is that we did not want to shed Russian
blood the second factor we went to
demonstrate our protest
and not to
overthrow the government in the country if
the action on February 24,
22  of the year,
at the beginning of the special operation, she performed
units according to the
level of training in terms of the level of
moral composure and readiness to
perform tasks like a dude, perhaps the
special operation would last
a day, we showed the level of organization
that the Russian army should correspond to